la fed a tutti ragazzi e benvenuto che
sono video sono felice ed oggi siamo
tornati su quel gioco bello che
praticamente tifa rispondere ai quiz ai
quali io non so rispondere su questo
gioco c'è veramente si crea il profilo
dove la gente può sfidarti e mandare
messaggi proprio da quando ho fatto il
video della settimana scorsa mi sono
arrivate giusto due o tre richieste di
persone che mi hanno invitato a fare una
partita con loro ci sono proprio
arrivate due o tre richieste e potrei
continuare tutto il giorno music live 12
mi ha sfidato a harry potter vediamo se
funziona la vediamo se riesco a far
meglio gli sto ragazzo che non ho letto
bene non non hai più vite a perché lo
sprecate tutte per l'episodio precedente
ricarica completa un euro ma correani
fanno spendere i soldi per recuperarle
vite ma [ __ ] che adesso i cuori si
pagano è mettiamo anche le tasse sul
buco del culo è bravo grazie ad esso che
mi hai [ __ ] né ore 06 vai alle
maldive brutto deficiente non si possono
spendere i soldi così [ __ ] che se
poi perdo vado a spendere tutto su place
royale è una cosa tra me e te adesso
perché se perdono perso un euro brutto
stronzo nella saga di harry potter qual
è il nome del ragno che grida accudisce
del cast mag
a me vuoi fregare su harry potter non
avete idea di quanto mi sia simpatico
quel cazzo di ragno quale l'incantesimo
che usa la migliore contro neville
vietri ficus totali qual è il luogo di
nascita di harry nella saga di harry
potter godric's hollow già su tutto c'è
un mercato russo dove sono nato io però
sto governatori potter in harry potter
ei doni della morte quanti harry ci sono
nella casa dei darsele vabbè 7 barca ho
vinto e americana seccate tutte le ha
fatto 20 domande tutte la zecca che
qualcuno mi ha sfidato sui miei quiz ma
siete scemi fa vj o di essere chiamato
lorenzo fa vigenti qual è il suo dj
preferito ma non lo ha mai detto martin
garics non ne 1 calvina rim chi cazzo e
calvin harris murray po per martin
harris i quali serie fa vj ha superato i
100 episodi islamica su 100 che vi
immaginate 100 episodi this lander man
che merda
in un blog aperto una bibita che è
esplosa che di vita era oddio anche coca
cola ma esplosa mi sono sposato che è la
pec si pensi a pezzi la vigesse mai
ubriacato la risposta giusta è sì per il
suo proprie anno ma in realtà anche in
un ristorante con amici però non lo sa
nessuno sinora dice no cazzo sbagliato
il compleanno era giusta comunque fa a
[ __ ] il video che all ex di fa vj
quante vi usava me ma che cazzo ne so 11
milioni 3 milioni 7 milioni un milione e
mezzo un milione e mezzo tre milioni ma
stai scherzando a [ __ ] qui che a 3
milioni e mezzo di valeria ma siete
pazzi non ne avevo idea però non è più
ma bastava che non è più vite ma
[ __ ] perché mi devi far spendere
un euro ogni tre minuti bastardo che
certo 32 euro per vite infinite ma
questi sono dei barbari sfidiamo
alexandra sull'attacco dei giganti
quanto sono alte le mura che difendono
la città o 50 o 60 100 da traiano
ricordavano posso perdere o non c'ho
voglia di dare un altro euro [ __ ]
chi fra i seguenti non ha mai perso un
arto mischia che bella domanda ma fa
ancora la mia seconda scelta ma ho solo
più una vita ragazzi poi dovrei dare un
altro euro dove si trova la squadra di
ribelli durante la 57ª spedisse ma
perché ho scelto le domande dell'attacco
dei giganti io porca eva che curò quanto
altro gigante been 7 la risposta esatta
è sempre 7 sempre ragazzi quando non
sapete una roba alla risposta e 7 sempre
qual è il nome della moglie di mille o
di o'neal quello di art attack alice non
lo so ragazzi non le domande suo attacco
i giganti non le so vabbè ho perso devo
spendere un altro euro e due ore che
spende un euro per andare avanti che due
[ __ ] muslin a gomez domande su se va
bè serio proviamo non lo so il sun
selena gomez non so se ne so completa la
frase dei camerieri
[Musica]
tra sei anni ovvero nel 2021 quanti anni
avrà selena gomez ma avrà 29 questa è
anche abbastanza semplice ne so più su
selena gomez che su me stesso quando
carico il video ufficiale di da hardouin
di quello 2014 ma [ __ ] biblioteche
non lo sapevo la vigile o cosa fa vj the
official a è un altro qui un altro tipo
di quiz che figo mi sono rotto il cazzo
basta basta secondo me è la fine visto
video mi blocca la carta per attività
sospette quanti video di minecraft ha
caricato sul suo canale va bene comunque
è una cosa che non ho capito chi è che
fasti quiz quale challenge ha fatto fa
vj questi genitori il rischio al gusto
challenge bella west e non ho tempo
amici sto registrando come si chiama
libero di fa vj sotto il sole il mio
libro sbagliato sotto l'ombra sottoli il
presto in libreria da pa vj sotto il
sole 10 guide su come avere
un'abbronzatura così bella cosa ha fatto
fa vj perché aveva troppo caldo addosso
chi è che ha fatto stato grande santo di
dio ancora possiamo fare ma sono rotto
il cazzo dei ragazzi scavo non ci ho più
voglia di di stuprare la mia carta di
credito o veramente se do la mia carta
di credito a una tipa e va a fare
shopping e mail non quello che episodio
grazie per avermi sfidato facciamo games
come mi piace sta roba per trovare
un'alternativa alle vite perché non è
normale se volete ragazzi sfidarmi mi
chiamo sutri via crack come cazzo si sa
nostro gioco bello di zio cola o che 10
credo che l'episodio di oggi spero che i
video vi sia piaciuto e cose di questo
argomento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook come nottata nelle schizzi
hansen e se avessi di scaricare i civili
diavolo fosse unito bella ragazza
[Musica]